that's right we have Michael Court
Akatsuki feel a vice president and he is
with Alejandro well not just feed a vice
president and you said it yourself a man
that wears many hats also the president
of the cabal of chests foundation and
many others Michael welcome to the show
welcome to the cares Cup thank thank you
for having me well tell us a little bit
about all the great things you do for
chess I mean it's in all aspects of it
well let's start with karyn's Cup that's
women's she has celebration here in st.
Louis for a second year and it's
absolutely incredible that reigning
world champion is here right after she
defended her title along with former
women's world champions and we have our
youngster Carrie Sahib
here who actually product of young star
programs that Casper arches Foundation
and chess club here in st. Louis are
doing together and obviously we're
rooting for her know by is there a
little bit more about this young stars
program I know that it's one of the key
successes that chess is had here in
America that produced some great great
players yes it's already our ninth year
of Young Start programs we have already
alums like Jeffrey Zhong who crossed
2700 and part of the u.s. teams and
sylveon and some others so now it's a
new group of young stars like Carrie
Sahib who its first super tournament and
in April she will flank us championship
again and she also already qualified for
the US team it's certainly big success
we have another young girl that working
with us is Rachelle bull who also
participated in 2019 in Kazakhstan
on for the US team and hopefully one day
she will join charissa in such torment I
don't know whether it would be fifth
chance cup for six but hopefully one day
they will play together and it would be
new generation of US women's yes
absolutely all the support that they're
getting I know that they're getting a
lot of coaching and it's really showing
in their game as they've progressed so
quickly I had even the pleasure of being
with both of these players in Kazakhstan
as their coach for the world team and I
have to say their ascension has been
tremendous charisa going from a 2,300
player last year to a full-fledged
IM you've basically organized a lot of
these successes for the kids so how does
it feel it feels in a extraordinary well
and because when you see the outcome of
the program then you you feel that you
completed your mission but we're not you
know stopping were just searching and
scouting for new talents
therefore we extended our program beyond
the United States and last year we
conducted our training program halls in
Zagreb in conjunction with Grantchester
classical event and this year we're
planning the same thing in Zagreb
another European session during ground
chest or wrap it in bleeds and cigrip as
well
well it's a great opportunity for the
players coaches foundations just not a
name only
Kasparov himself that's a lot of these
weekend long or even a little bit longer
training sessions yes we're doing two
training sessions in the United States
one in st. Louis and June and in
December in New York Kasparov himself is
working for the weekend
with select a group of kids and in
Zagreb as well and you are mentioning
it's coinciding with a grand chest tour
which you also play a heavy part in yeah
you know trying to assemble the group of
enthusiasts
who actually sponsoring events on one
end and another and who can produce this
and obviously I have to praise you and
yessir and Jennifer as our great
commentators and the best broadcast
group in the world question for you I
you are also the vice president of PETA
and recently we saw all that there's
been a big increase in the world Women's
Championship purse and that's also the
case here at the Karen's Cup a big
increase from last year's prize fund so
you see this direction as something that
might incentivize girls to stick which
has longer yes that's the plan actually
the presidential board we have discussed
this several times and through the
president himself committed to pay more
attention to women's chess moreover not
only involve female players to play but
also female players organizers storming
directors to be involved in
organizational part and even in feed
structures so about a year ago at the
presidential board meeting in Kazakhstan
in conjunction with a World Team
Championship we actually passed a
resolution that 20 percent of
presidential board should consist of
female so and also every single
Commission in fee that also should
shouldn t have women in in those
Commission's so therefore this is one of
the first steps that actually we took
during our meetings since we did great
at least 20 percent right yes yes the
meaning
well Michael thank you so much for
joining us here at the Cairns couple let
you enjoy some of the games before I
know you have a lot of things to do
it sounds like you're involved in every
part of chess and well we thank you for
it yeah it's my pleasure and thank you
for inviting me
[Music]